hace ya unos varios vídeos que vimos que
podemos parametrizar un toro o lo que es
la forma de una de una dona de una dona
de las que nos comemos verdad como una
función vectorial de posición que
depende de dos variables es decir de dos
parámetros y bueno lo enseña hace unos
vídeos era un poco difícil pero voy a
reescribir esta función vectorial como
la función r que depende de nuestros
parámetros s&p y luego vamos a repasar
un poco lo que significaban esto es
verdad que tenía por ahí unas hadas de
unas veces entonces la función erre
estará dada por de más a coseno de s
donde hay b son constantes verdad quizás
quieras repasar los vídeos sobre la
parametrización de superficies con dos
parámetros para entender cómo es que
llegamos aquí y luego esta expresión que
les decía lo multiplicamos por seno de t
ahora todo esto irán multiplicando al
vector y que lo voy a dejar en los
vectores en color color naranja
ahora sumamos de más a coseno de s por y
ahora vamos a multiplicar por el coseno
coseno de t muy bien y todo esto va en
la dirección j
recordemos que es una superficie en la
tercera en el espacio de tres
dimensiones así que falta una última
entrada que será a seno de ese por el
vector en la dirección del eje z que es
acá y esto es lo que nos genera la
figura de la dona o el toro ahora para
no envolvernos con pues no sé muchos
detalles y demás este solo vamos a poner
que ese es mayor o igual que 0 y menor
que 2 pi y que la t está entre 0 y 2 pi
perfecto ahora vamos a distribuir está
este ejemplo en varios vídeos pero bueno
vamos a repasar de dónde vino todo esto
aquí está un intento de dibujar una una
rosquilla una dona qué
o un toro pues y bueno puedes imaginarlo
verdad es esto es la forma de una dona
ahora tenemos un círculo que es una
sección transversal por ejemplo este que
pintamos en azul todos estos
todos estos y después tenemos un círculo
que envuelve a todo es verdad así
así cuando derivamos la fórmula de acá
arriba la fórmula que tenemos arriba a
era el radio de estas secciones
transversales este es a esta que estamos
subrayando y ve era la distancia del
centro del toro del centro del toro
centro de estas secciones transversales
esta es nuestra distancia ve que estamos
pintando en amarillo así que podemos
imaginar que ves como el radio del toro
verdad que es la distancia del centro al
centro del centro del toro al centro de
cada sección transversal y cuando lo
parametrizados el parámetro s
esencialmente nos está diciendo a qué
grado a qué grado estamos envolviendo al
círculo de este circulito azul así que
el ángulo pues está entre 0 y 2 p verdad
nos está diciendo que tanto hemos girado
en este círculo transversal ahora la t
funciona igual pero con este este
círculo que es como digamos ecuatorial
sí
y estamos pensando en la t como el
ángulo que recorremos a lo largo de la
de lado nano en su sección transversal y
bueno vimos en vídeos anteriores cómo
cómo calcular ahora la integral de una
superficie verdad la integral de
superficie nos va a dar la super fila
perdón el área de este toro
así que si a este toro le llamamos sigma
y lo representamos como la función
vectorial r que depende de dos
parámetros aceite
si está sigma es la imagen de todos esos
valores
entonces ya vimos que la integral de
superficie como lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior pues está integrada al doble
sobre sigma que es la superficie en
realidad representa la suma de una
superficie de un montón de de sigma es
verdad donde décimas las podemos
imaginar como pequeños parches hitos en
nuestro toro
una siesta está digamos podría ser de
sigma es una doble integral porque
queremos integrar sobre una superficie
de dos dimensiones verdad podríamos
pensar que integramos en una dirección
transversal y en una longitudinal a lo
largo de todo el toro por eso es que
usamos una doble integral perfecto ahora
el punto central del vídeo y
posiblemente de otros dos es es calcular
este integral así que en realidad
calcular la integral pues podría haber
en el integrando una función escalar
verdad pero en este caso sólo estamos
multiplicando por 1 y lo que vimos en el
último vídeo es que realmente pues no se
puede hacer mucho con esta expresión
pero una forma de llevar esta integral
es como lo vimos en el vídeo reciente es
verdad esto es lo mismo que la integra
al doble sobre la región sobre la que se
definen los parámetros es decir existe
ambos están entre 0 y 2 pi correcto
cualquiera que sea la función que
tengamos dentro aquí sólo tenemos un 1
así que podemos escribir
por de sigma que en realidad es la
magnitud de la parcial de r respecto de
s cruz la parcial de r la derivada
parcial de r respecto de t estamos
haciendo esta magnitud y ahora vamos a
integrar por supuesto
respecto de ese y respecto de t como lo
vimos en el último vídeo lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es realmente calcularlo ese
es el punto central de este vídeo vamos
a tomar el producto cruz de estos dos
vectores y de hecho vamos a calcular los
vectores y después veremos ya que es lo
que prosigue en esta doble integral
vamos a ver qué es un problema bastante
difícil bueno es engorroso y quizás por
eso algunas personas nunca han hecho una
integral de superficie en su vida pero
de todos modos nosotros si lo vamos a
hacer así que primero la parcial de r
respecto de s pues es es que es el
término que subrayamos en realidad es
derivar respecto de s cada uno
cada una de las componentes de r y
ponerlos como un vector verdad así que
en realidad si derivamos la primera
respecto de s pues tenemos b por el seno
de t que es una constante si
distribuimos ese producto y después a
coseno de s por seno de t hacen o dt es
constante por lo tanto solo derivamos
coseno de s que es menos s perdón
menos seno de s así que terminamos
poniendo menos a por el seno de t
seno de ese verdad eso es la derivada de
la primera componente revísalo si no te
quedó muy claro pero bueno concluimos
que esto es menos a seno de tss y
finalmente multiplicamos por el vector y
ahora derivamos la segunda componente
respecto de s otra vez y distribuimos
tenemos b por coseno dt que es una
constante ay coseno de t es una
constante para el segundo sumando por lo
tanto sólo hay que derivar coseno de s
que nuevamente la derivada de eso es
menos seno de s
así que este el resultado de derivar
respecto desde la segunda componente es
menos a por el coseno de t
y ahora por el seno de s
seno de s
y finalmente hay que multiplicar
nuevamente por el vector unitario j y
ahora derivamos respecto desde la última
componente aquí es muy sencillo verdad a
es una constante y la derivada del seno
de s simplemente es coseno de s así que
ponemos a coseno de s y multiplicamos
por nuestro vector unitario acá
muy bien espero que no haya sido muy
confuso si no puedes hacerlo con mucho
cuidado tú mismo en realidad solo
derivamos lo que estaba entre los
paréntesis de las primeras dos
componentes y eso fue lo que nos dio los
resultados y bueno en la última
componente era inmediato verdad ahora
hagamos lo mismo con respecto a te vamos
a vamos a hacerlo de otro color para que
sea más vistoso entonces vamos a tomar
la derivada parcial de r respecto de t
perfecto entonces todo esto es una
constante en la primera en la primera
entrada de más a coseno de s
es una constante por lo tanto ahí se
queda y ahora derivamos seno de t la
derivada de seno dt es coseno dt y
simplemente le ponemos ahora el vector y
porque lo multiplicamos por s de nueva
cuenta en la segunda componente de más a
coseno de s
es una constante que multiplica coseno
de t esto para fines de derivar respecto
dt verdad y ahora la derivada de coseno
dt es menos seno de t por eso ponemos el
signo menos a la izquierda y seno desde
a la derecha y después lo multiplicamos
por nuestra constante
perfecto y finalmente la última
componente no depende de ti por lo tanto
es una constante si derivamos una
constante respecto de t pues entonces
simplemente tendremos cero así que lo
vamos a escribir como 0 por nuestro
vector perdón
vamos a dejarlo en ese color verdad 0
por nuestro vector unitario que eso nos
da nuestras dos derivadas parciales de r
y ahora hay que hacer el producto cruz y
tomar la magnitudes después tomaremos la
integral doble pero ya lo haremos en
otros vídeos